ihr kennt das mit sicherheit wenn man
gefragt wird was meine ganzen park
gemacht wo man dann sagt man eigentlich
nichts aber ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich
nicht komplett nichts gemacht sondern
euch mit auf dem handy oder computer
oder sonstwas abgelenkt ich frage mich
was passiert wenn man das mal durch zu
entwickeln den ganzen tag lang absolut
nichts markt kein handy kein computer
kein kontakt zu anderen menschen kann er
arbeit keine schule keinen stress kann
spaß und keine ablenkung ich werde heute
den ganzen tag lang da sitzen kein
finger krümmen und einfach gar nichts
machen um herauszufinden was dabei mit
einem verstand und meinem körper
passieren werde ich damit kommen wir
zurück in meine gliedmaßen ab werde ich
dadurch erleichtert wie ein mönch oder
bekommen fähig komplette halluzination
werden am ende diesen einzugs komplett
langweilige sagt ein mega viel spaß
machen und ohnehin schon spaßige sache
nicht komplett zur ekstase bringt los
geht's schon nach ungefähr 20 sekunden
werde ich ungeduldig ist fühlt sich an
als würde ich auf irgendetwas warten
ohne der aussicht dass dieses etwas
eintreffen könnte eine minute ein
beengtes gefühl maxime er bereit ist
fühlt sich ein bisschen so an als wenn
man in einem raum eingesperrt der so eng
ist dass man nicht mal seine arme nach
oben heben kann
wer nicht gerade mein ding machen nehme
ich euch mal mit auf eine zeitreise noch
vor 30 jahren sahen normaler tag
wahrscheinlich so aus man steht auf und
hatte sich 1980 von normalen ist schon
lange nicht mehr schwarz war ist man
steht auf und geht auf die toilette man
sitzt entspannt da und nach genau gar
nichts danach kurz an seine zähne und
vornehmen weil seine gewinnspanne von
von gar keinem anschließend ist dann wie
ein komplett verrückter sein frühstück
ohne sich dabei ein youtube video
anschauen und macht sich danach auf dem
weg zur arbeit an der bahn angekommen
genau man sitzt einfach nur da und
wartet einfach dass die bahn da ist in
der bahn passiert weil dieses video und
macht für alle minute lang
was vor 30 jahren noch das normalste der
welt war ist für moderne menschen im
besten fall unangenehm und ich denke das
hat etwas damit zu tun dass wir uns in
jeder freien sekunde mit irgendwelchen
dingen beschäftigen
okay aber jetzt wieder zurück zum
experiment die dritte minute noch
niemals wandfarbe so interessant wie es
mir fallen kleine dunkle flecken dran
auf welche nur noch nie bewusst waren
zehn minuten
ich presse ab in endlose kette von
tagträume welche ineinander übergehen
und mein bewusstsein fesseln nach dem
was sich anfühlt wie zwei stunden wache
ich aus den tagträumen auf und schaue
auf die uhr 15 minuten
wir haben exakt 2 prozent des
experiments abgeschlossen spitze eine
halbe stunde da die ersten 15 minuten
wirklich beklemmt waren probiere ich
setz mit meditation wenn um ehrlich zu
sein ist tagträumen ja immer noch etwas
und nicht nichts meditation hingegen hat
nicht nur das ziel nichts zu tun sondern
auch an nichts zu denken
richtig spannend wird es zu sehen was
nach mehreren stunden passiert aber
davor muss ich euch nochmal entführen
die meditation ist eine
bewusstseinserweiternde übung bei der
zustände angestrebt werden welche sich
mit stille lehre oder 1 zahlen
beschreiben lassen könnten ich meditiere
schon seit einigen jahren ab aber nie
länger als zwei monate am stück täglich
durchgezogen es gibt hunderte
meditationsübungen aber für mich
funktioniert am besten mit hinzusetzen
und zuerst meine atemzüge bis zehn zu
zählen und danach wieder bei der einst
anzufangen wobei ich bei den ungeraden
zahlen immer ein arzt mir und bei den
geraden immer auch immer wenn meine
gedanken abdriften bringe ich meine
aufmerksamkeit zurück auf den atem
dadurch trainiert man diese ganzen
zwischenrufe der gedanken zu
kontrollieren wenn ich mich bereit
gehörig nach einigen minuten damit auf
und versuche an nichts zu denken nicht
persönlich muss um an komplett gar
nichts denken zu können meinen körper
komplett entspannen da ich dadurch
nochmal umkippen würde versuche ich
meinen körper perfekt zu demonstrieren
um mich auf mich selbst zu stützen ob
ich dabei wirklich jeden muskel komplett
entspannen bezweifle ich aber auf jeden
fall fühlt es sich danach an weil ich
kann nur durch meinen verstanden
zusammen mit meinem körper entspannen
und dann nichts denken das habe ich
bisher noch nie länger als 40 minuten
gemacht und na ja wir haben noch ein
paar stunden forums nach 45 minuten
wovon ca 15 meditation waren bin ich an
dem punkt an dem ich mich balanciere und
mich komplett fallen lasse
eine stunde und fünf minuten nach gerade
mal 20 minuten verlangt mein magen immer
mehr nach essen ich habe am anfang
versucht zu unterdrücken habe irgendwann
nicht mehr ausgehalten
ich mache jetzt schon seit über einer
stunde nichts und langsam
meine wahrnehmung lustig ich würde das
zwar nicht als trans bezahlen aber es
fühlt sich schon ziemlich unwirklich an
und nach weiteren 20 minuten habe ich es
in diesem zustand auch endlich mal
geschafft ein paar scheiben knäckebrot
zu essen zweite stunde ich habe jetzt 40
minuten am stück meditiert wobei ich
etwas schwierigkeiten hatte obwohl mir
das durch das vorherige nichts tun ja
eigentlich leicht fallen hätte sollen es
hat den eindruck gemacht als wäre durch
das ganze nichts tun meine fantasie
derart angeregt worden dass es jetzt
umso schwieriger ist diese abzustellen
und dann nichts zu denken
hinzu kommt dass ich langsam immer
dringender auf die toilette muss ich
will erst versuchen das ganze zu
unterdrücken muss mir aber eingestehen
dass das genauso unmöglich ist wie
vorher beim hunger 3 stunden und 20
minuten nachdem ich über eine stunde
teils meditiert teils löcher in die luft
gestemmt habe ist mein kopf mittlerweile
derart much dass ich beim erneuten
knäckebrot festmahl des öfteren während
ich esse gefühlt in eine andere
dimension gezogen werde und dann nicht
jetzt zum beispiel für fünf minuten lang
mit den knäckebrot zwischen meinen
zähnen herumhängen und einfach nur in
einer ecke schauer sechste stunde
ich habe so gut wie kein zeitgefühl
manchmal trifft sich ab und eine stunde
vergeht wie eine minute manchmal ist es
wirklich fast unerträglich nur
umzusetzen und eine minute vergeht wir
eine stunde
[Musik]
jetzt ist der abend angekommen und damit
zeit endlich wieder etwas zu tun was
mich abgesehen von nichtstun am meisten
interessiert war wie es sich anfühlt
jetzt etwas langweiliges zu tun
ich habe mir erhofft dass zum beispiel
aufräumen jetzt total viel spaß macht
und obwohl das aufräumen für die ersten
zwei minuten auch erträglicher war als
sonst habe ich eher das gefühl dass ich
durch das ganze nichts tun jetzt umso
mehr etwas tun will wissen wir wirklich
spaß macht und eben nicht aufbauen zum
fazit also ich finde es cool dass ich
durchgezogen habe ich das war dass er
nicht zum ende wirklich wirklich
schwierig es war an und für sich war
nicht cool ist
ich habe keine drogen genommen aber es
war wirklich crazy teilweise und auch
wenn ich denke das ist nicht unbedingt
sinnvoll ist dass man jede kleine pause
des nichtstuns durch handy oder sowas
austauscht würde ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt jedem empfehlen meinen ganzen
nächstes machen außer wenn man schon mal
testen werden weil zum ende hin habe ich
mich einmal wirklich nur gefreut dass es
vorbei war
ich mach beinahe jede woche eines
experiments erwarten hier auch menschen
mit eurem filmen oder video begeistern
möchte dann kann ich euch meinen
schnittkurs empfehlen und wenn euch
jetzt langweilig ist dann kann ich euch
dieses video empfehlen und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dadurch langweilig wenn
er nicht auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte dann folgt doch mir und meinem
zweiten kanal und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]